la famille rothschild et la banque
rothschild sont extrêmement connue en
europe est aussi très riche mais d'où
vient cette fortune mais faut faire
intervenir la tricherie il fausse
nouvelle
il s'attend nous sommes en 1846 un petit
pamphlet est publié à paris dans lequel
on peut lire la manière dont la famille
rothschild a acquis sa fortune l'auteur
un certain satin je vous rassure c'est
un nom d'emprunt
c'est un homme de gauche britannique qui
veut attaquer la famille rothschild et
plus spécifiquement nathan rothschild
pourquoi il faut venir en juin 1815
selon le conflit on raconte que nathan
rothschild aurait assisté à la bataille
de waterloo la bataille de waterloo voit
le duc de wellington battre napoléon
donc une défaite française et rothschild
aurait été un des premiers à prendre
cette nouvelle
qu'est-ce qui fait il prend cheval court
si rapide et gagne la manche harilala
venge
il ya un orage il peut pas traverser un
pêcheur pas loin de là et il vaut lui
payer une somme du don royal pour
traverser la manche il arrive à la
banque de londres et là il réalise un
coup d'argent qui lui rapporte des
tonnes et des tonnes de livres sterling
pourquoi parce qu'il ne sût avant tout
le monde
la défaite française donc la fortune des
rothschild aurait été fait sur ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier une espèce de
tricherie ou un délit d'initié comme on
appelle aujourd'hui sauf que quand on
avance un peu dans l'histoire on se rend
compte que ce pamphlet là ne rapporte
pas complètement la réalité ce petit
pamphlet c'est faux et notre fameux
nathan rothschild que vous avez ici 20
il n'était pas à waterloo non non non il
n'était pas là et plus encore les
historiens qui ont travaillé sur la
question se rendent compte qu'il y avait
plusieurs personnes qui ont su avant
tout le monde
la défaite française
mais pourquoi est ce qu'on a dit ça
pourquoi est-ce qu'on attaque rothschild
banque rothschild et juifs
il ya un antisémitisme latent en europe
c'est une manière de s'attaquer ou juifs
et de dire que les juifs sont prêts à
tout même triché pour avoir de l'argent